[Music]
you know one truth time for the Jedi and
that your boy yes and are you speaking
to Rey responsible I think there's a
response in there and it sounds like
it's my voice is it you that same time
for the Jedi to end is so what has
happened to you well to reach this point
I think that's the only story point
that's in the teaser it was a shocking
to me to read what Ryan had written as
I'm sure it will be for the audience I
think how the losted eye starts and the
journey we go on is perhaps unexpected
do you make a turn to the dark side
is it possible there's definitely an
element of mentorship and training that
happens between the two of them but it's
not an exact mirror of training that
we've seen before we seem to be much
more proficient with a lightsaber
everybody wants to know who you are
where you're from who your parents are
will that all be answered in the last
Jedi and it's very interesting because I
didn't know Mark was telling me I didn't
know that when Darth Vader said I'm your
father
people didn't believe it they didn't
believe it was true and it was
interesting because at the end of force
way because I thought everyone's going
to I'll call that's been answered but it
hasn't and I think even though a lot of
questions are asked in the last Jedi I
think it's still that thing of discovery
are we going to find out who her parents
are you tell me it's it's something that
is absolutely going to be addressed in
the movie it will be addressed there
will be the clarification it depends on
I'm not ant say I was about to say I
almost got me kiri Fisher will be in the
last Jedi - she completed filming before
her death but questions remain about the
fate of her character in the series
feature films back recently Fisher's
brother Todd till daily news
confidential the Princess Leia would
appear in Star Wars Episode nine he was
probably um
confused sadly Kari will not be a nun
I'm in a back to suit in a medical
facility because of the lightsabres
guards he still go for recovery he's
joined by actress Kelly Marie Tran who
plays a new character named Rose she's
part of the resistance she gets wrapped
up in this insane adventure there's a
mission that needs to be accomplished
and Finn and Rose golf Alana an amazing
adventure together and and that in
itself gives birth to new things that
were spirited there's an infinite number
of wonderful stories to be told in this
universe
happy Star Wars day everyone so I wanted
to post this fun cobbled together
interview where they confirm a bunch of
really cool things about the trailer in
episode 8 so there's a new brand of the
Star Wars giveaway is just for the rogue
one blu-ray all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video so let's just do this in
order of really big confirmations big
reveals mark hamill confirms that he's
the one that says it's time for the Jedi
to end there were a lot of people that
thought it might be Benicio del Toro
because as he's gotten older his voice
is a little more corrupt in his Luke
voice is very different from the voice
that he uses when he's doing other
acting roles so the little confusing but
if you zoom in really closely on his
silhouette there you can kind of see his
lips moving during the trailer but the
follow up to that sort of addresses the
issue about what he wants to come next
because when she asked if he's going to
go evil he's like it's possible but he
says it in a really offhanded ridiculous
way like yet that's you know could
happen but probably not I think the
reason that most people are wondering
about that is because of the way he's
mirrored with kylo Ren on the other side
of her saber way up here in the red and
she's the only beacon of hope down here
at the bottom so I don't think that
means that he's going evil to the dark
side I think it just implies that he's
in a very bad place and they said that
the characters would end the movie in a
very bad place same way they did during
Empire Strikes Back even though there
will be a lot of hope in the movie it's
very dark in Luke and kylo Ren sort of
represent this old school of thought
kylo Ren is team Vader he's all about
Vader's way Luke is all about the Jedi
way now he's come to the realization
that the old way won't work anymore so I
think that's all that's implied by
what's going on here now they're very
cryptic about how they tease the Journal
of the Wills either they told her she
wasn't allowed to ask about specifics or
they cut it out of the interview but the
books that they find is a really big
part of the trailer so I'll talk about
that in a second - because Rian
Johnson's reveal was probably my
favorite thing out of this also finding
out about Finn and Rosa's side mission
so the next big thing is Rian Johnson
just confirming that they're not going
to be repeating the training montage
that Luke had with Yoda and Daisy Ridley
has talked about this too so I'll link
that video at the end of this but she
says that she comes to Luke he doesn't
know who she is but he recognizes the
saber and is very worried and because
she's built up the myth of Luke
Skywalker and her head
she has all these expectations for him
but you can see here he's kind of a
failure the way that Mark Hamill
explained it so instead of becoming this
amazing Jedi Master it's all in ruins
now so emotionally he's kind of in ruins
and physically as well because he's been
searching for the original Jedi Temple
for a long time so just implied that he
might not be as forthcoming a master or
as confident in his own abilities as a
teacher as Yoda was or even obi-wan
Kenobi in the brief time he spent trying
to teach Luke don't let that bum you out
though I have a feeling that being with
Rey is going to reinvigorate his
character and there'll be some really
badass Luke scenes in Episode eight
they're not here to bum you out this is
supposed to be a really awesome movie
even though it's going to be dark but
the next big thing is then talking about
Rey's parents so she says that she
didn't know when she was at the end of
Episode seven she thought that it would
be revealed but then Rian Johnson
catches himself before he answers so the
way he ducks the question is very
important he gives kind of a half answer
he says it will definitely be addressed
and then she sort of pushes him a little
more in when he answers again and stops
himself I think what he was getting
ready to say is it depends on what you
mean by clarification so what I think
that implies is that they won't outright
say this person that person is raised
parents but you'll find out who they are
only it'll just raise more questions so
there won't be any real clarification
but you'll actually know who it's not
and I think it will tease a larger
mystery that'll play out over Episode
nine so probably the best theory that I
have now is that they're searching for
the Journal of the Wills this book here
about the origins of the force the true
path that was mistranslated by the Jedi
and the Sith the Wills are this ancient
race that supposedly had a much greater
understanding of the force than any of
the Jedi or the Sith in any other force
practitioners that came after them so
they just want to go back to get the
original Bible of the force so as they
continue to tease out the idea of who
the Wills are it's still very cryptic
Star Wars hasn't done a lot with them
yet but there is a brand new book about
them called guardians of the Wills
surprise surprise so it's almost like
they're pushing us in the direction that
Rey might be descended from the Wills so
that doesn't mean that she's not related
to any of the other characters in the
series right now it just means that her
origins might be much more mysterious
than you thought before so they
referenced the Darth Vader M
higher reveal Luke I am your father
there's almost no twist in any movie
that you could do to top that other than
say you are the daughter of this
mythical race of beings that had the
ultimate knowledge of the force even
though she has absolutely no idea what
that means
it would just reinforce the idea that
she's part of this new thing that
they're trying to create in the absence
of the Jedi but if you guys want I will
do a separate video about the Wills
they're really interesting and I'm still
reading that guardians of the Wills book
so once I'm done with it I'll do some
more videos about it but the next big
thing is just confirming the Carrie
Fisher is not going to be in episode 9
at all the way Kathleen Kennedy talks
about it they're like no there will be
no Leia at all so we can make some
guesses about what happens to her
character but because it's Star Wars day
just to pay respect to the character
will say that she will always be
important to the legacy of Star Wars so
whatever happens to her in the movie her
story will be carried forward by the
other characters like Ben solo her son
but the last big thing John boyega just
confirming that finn is in a bhakta suit
here that he eventually gets out and he
and Rose go on a special mission on
their own but there's a lot of rumors
that they're going to have to infiltrate
the first order so he'll find himself
back in the path of phasma they've
already confirmed she's going to be a
lot of fun but obviously you have to
have a reason to go have scenes there
and it would just be that much more
compelling to throw Finn back into her
path because that's where he started so
secret agent Finn and Rose are going to
be having all the fun but here's the
Star Wars Day message that Ryan Johnson
posted of him and John Williams they're
scouring the movie right now hey this is
ryan johnson the writer and director of
star wars the last Jedi and I'm here
with someone you might know hello John
hello have you got anything to say to
everybody on this 4th of May well I will
say may the force be with you
ok back to work back to work but let me
know what you guys think based on what
ryan johnson said or did not say about
the reveal of Rey's parents how do you
think that's going to be tied to their
mission for this ancient Jedi knowledge
the knowledge of the Wills
and leave all your requests for Star
Wars videos in the comments below but
what's going to happen is as tomorrow
I'll start posting more guardians of the
galaxy so be sure and go see the movie
while you wait for everything you can
click here for my guardians of the
galaxy review and you can
here for all my Star Wars Episode eight
videos thank you so much for watching
let's high-five happy Star Wars day
everybody